des gilets jaunes dans les gradins du
palais des sports des longs cours une
rencontre débat entre citoyens était
organisée ce vendredi 22 février par des
figures du mouvement
une première dans les yvelines mais le
concept n'est pas inédit en france ont
fait en moyenne des salles de 1000
personnes et on prépare des salles
encore plus grande pour juste faire voir
que on existe on n'est pas des foule
haineuse ya pas de casseurs dans les
salles
donc on fait des débats on va faire des
vagues genre on pose des questions on va
répondre aux questions et les gens vont
être un peu plus au courant de ce qu'on
peut demander ce qu'on peut réclamer
pour un peu plus de justice sociale et
fiscale dans la salle plus de 450
curieux et militants venus
principalement des civils et des
départements limitrophes avaient fait le
déplacement des gens en échange entre
citoyens on y retrouve tous bords
politiques
donc on est dans le concret pour moi on
est dans le concret voilà je pense qu'on
va ressortir plus intelligents qu'on
était entré je pense enfin pris le plus
informé en tout cas après qu'est-ce
qu'elle sera le la pacte sur le reste de
la population c'est à nous de porter la
bonne parole après à nous deux
d'essayer de convaincre les gens s'ils
ne sont pas déjà convaincu au total et
gilet jaune et leurs représentants ont
pu débattre pendant plus de trois heures
ce soir là un concept qui pourrait se
développer selon les organisateurs ça
permet d'échanger dans un autre cadre
parce qu on échange beaucoup au coeur
des manifestations
et c'est pas un contexte idéal pour
discuter avec les autres il est jeune
donc pourquoi pas avoir ce type de
formule 1 je trouve que c'est une bonne
évolution de la mobilisation les
organisateurs n'excluent pas de revenir
dans les prochains mois dans les
yvelines pour toucher encore plus de
citoyens